the race to go back to the moon just got
tighter see a few years ago nasa said it
wanted two companies to build lunar
landers for its artemis mission which
aims to return humans to the moon for
the first time in around half a century
but then last year the agency said it
was only awarding one lunalander
contract to spacex that decision drew
criticism from rival bidders like
jeffrey bezos's blue origin who called
it a mistake and a missed opportunity
and even tried to sue the government
because of it but now bezos might be
able to get back in that race see the
biden administration recently proposed
boosting nasa's lunar budget and
sketched out plans for further increases
in the years ahead it is a significant
increase over last year's budget the
money hasn't received congressional
approval yet but nasa is already
inviting companies to bid to build
additional landers to carry astronauts
to the lunar surface so if nasa is going
to go back to the moon who is trying to
take them there and why is this race so
important for them let's find out
okay to understand what's up for grabs
you need to know what the different
elements of the artemis mission are
because the path to the moon has a lot
of moving parts
first off there's the space launch
system a huge rocket made by boeing
northrop grumman and others which will
be used to propel a crew capsule into
space that crew capsule is called orion
and it's made by lockheed martin now
orion won't land on the moon but will
instead hang around in lunar orbit and
act as a kind of initial base for people
going down to the moon's surface and
nasa also has long-term plans to build
something called gateway kind of like a
truck stop in lunar orbit to get from
gateway or orion to that's one small
you need a different spacecraft that can
take you from luna orbit down to the
lunar surface and back and that's where
those lunar landers come in one of those
lunar landers will be built by spacex
essentially spacex has been hired to use
a version of starship to take astronauts
from orion and transport them down to
the lunar surface starship is the
vehicle of the future for spacex it's
meant to be their rocket and space
vehicle to handle the most ambitious
deepest space flights and missions in
the future according to nasa spacex was
chosen as it had proposed the lowest
initial price but now that nasa is
potentially getting some extra funding
the agency is on the hunt for a second
lander provider and that's where jeff
bezos's blue origin could come back in
now they have another chance potentially
to bid on this this new round
blue origin was part of a group that
initially proposed a design that had
separate descent ascent and transfer
units the lando was to be constructed in
conjunction with other companies
including lockheed martin and northrop
grumman which blue origin referred to as
the national team after spacex won the
original bid for proposing that lowest
initial price bezos offered to knock up
to two billion dollars off the cost of
his project and offered other benefits
to nasa too his company also published
this infographic criticizing spacex's
approach but nasa didn't change its mind
they said they essentially had budgetary
constraints
and and couldn't sort of commit to two
different options at that time but now
if that funding passes the companies
said after nasa announced this that
they're ready to compete
but you may wonder why this mission is
such a big deal for spacex and blue
origin after all both companies have
successfully sent people into space
independently of nasa well part of it is
about securing future lucrative
contracts with nasa as the agency isn't
just planning on returning to the moon
briefly it has plans to establish a
sustained presence there we expect to
land
about once a year
for more than a decade as part of its
new funding nasa is giving more work to
spacex to land people on the moon under
its existing contract but for these
companies the artemis mission could
serve as a launch pad for their bigger
ambitions see both jeff bezos and elon
musk have said they have plans to turn
the human race into an interplanetary
species i think this is just
an incredibly important thing for the
future of life itself
if that's your your sort of big goal you
want to be deeply immersed and involved
in the particular programs as they come
up taking humans back to the lunar
surface is a
about as high of a profile of a mission
as you can imagine so buckle up because
while this race may be getting pretty
interesting the moon
may be just the beginning
hey the last time we went to the moon
was for the apollo 17 mission and the
astronauts there spent three days on the
lunar surface so now you know and if you
want to know more don't forget to
subscribe see you soon
[Music]